i am i'm rockbot on the interwebs so
follow me whatever I work at NPM NPM
started out as open-source but it's a
company now and I was actually employee
number one and as employee number one I
was a web engineer and then I moved up
to being a tech lead in the web team and
now I'm the engineering manager for the
web team and today what I'd like to do
is kind of take you through NPM kind of
like to stir it over but let's just kind
of play with NPM a bit today but before
I do that the first thing I want to do
is kind of talk a little bit about NPM
NPM is a package manager for JavaScript
a lot of people think NPM means node
package manager
it turns out it doesn't mean that it's
just three random letters that someone
put together it you could say that it
has no prescribed meaning okay but
here's the other funny saying Java
scripts a bit of an is a misnomer as
well because there's CSS in our
repository earth in the registry there's
go there's rust there's C++ so in
reality NPM is just a package manager
but I'd like to think it's pretty cool
and our number one priority at NPM is to
reduce friction you all have an
important job to do you want to write
code push to production make cool stuff
the last thing you want is to have your
tools get in the way so everything we do
every product you build every service we
create the major takeaway for us is is
this going to make your lives easier so
with all of that in mind let's build an
app our app is going to be a random
wombat fact generator and it's going to
be a command-line client because we
don't have a lot of time and I just kind
of want to get moving
whatever now this is a wombat it's a
marsupial native to Australia and you're
PI wondering why wombats that seems
ridiculous well it turns out if you take
the NPM logo and you flip it around it
no longer says NPM it says wdu which
obviously not obviously really means
wombat developer Union and all of the
people at NPM we've refer to ourselves
as wombats and this is our little mascot
and if you want to know why were the
wombat developer Union and why we chose
a wombat in the first place come find me
afterwards I have a bunch of stickers we
can talk about wombats and NPM and all
that good stuff okay so I'm going to
start talking really really really fast
the good news is this is being recorded
so you can go onto YouTube later and you
can go ahead and put it down to a one
point or a point five X so that you're
not talking about fast but we've a lots
of stuff to cover so great okay the
first thing that we're gonna do in
building this app we are going to
install node J s if you haven't already
I personally prefer to go to node J s
org - and press the big green button
it's easy it's fast you can use homebrew
or whatever else you want I just prefer
to go straight to the source
now NPM comes bundled with node but N
Pam's release process is at a different
rate then nodes release process and
we're gonna hear all about nodes release
process later for miles but suffice it
to say that most of the time when you're
installing node you probably have a
slightly out of date NPM in fact if it's
been a few weeks since you updated NPM
go ahead and update it again so you want
to go and Pam I NPM at latest Ashby
fantastic okay now let's get to building
this app are we ready we're gonna do
this live to do okay so here we are
we're in our nice little terminal
fantastic and the first thing I want to
point out is that any time you have
questions or whatever from right within
your terminal you can ask ask for help
and it's really it's an easy you can
just kind of be like alright well what
do i do how does this work fantastic
okay moving on so the first thing we're
going to do is we're going to create a
directory
of random wombat facts this is gonna be
our application and if you're looking at
this and going what kind of syntax is
that that's not bash it's cuz it's fish
shell I like it I'm not gonna have a
shell war with you but I'm okay
so we're creating an application so the
first thing that we're gonna do is we're
gonna do NPM an it now NPM an it is an
automated tool to create a package dot
JSON your package JSON is essentially a
manifest file for your entire app it's
where the computers basically gonna say
okay what dependencies do you have what
is the name of your app what version is
it on what's the description all of
those good things
now you could of course totally make it
by yourself but why would you do that
I'm a lazy developer I don't know if
you're lazy developers but I'm totally
lazy developer and if I can I totally
want my computer to do all the work for
me so here we are in this automated tool
and anything that's in parentheses is
kind of a default and so I'm like okay
you know what named random wombat backs
that sounds great version 1.0.0
fantastic description random wombat fact
generate or fantastic entry point we're
gonna have some file called index at J s
that sounds good we won't have any tests
just ignore that and no get repo
whatever it's fine we're doing it live
and so wombats fast jazz cough fantastic
so some keywords that will be useful for
searches later and then you need to add
a license now is C is a pretty standard
open-source license but in the event
that you don't want to license something
you know what you don't have to license
it you can just say unlicensed is this
okay yes sounds great so now all we have
in here is just a simple back package
JSON and that's what it looks like and
this is what's gonna be stored in the
registry and this is what the website
uses to kind of show off what version
you're on and all that good stuff okay
so we know that our entry point is
indexed is so we're going to go ahead
and build that so let's do an index J is
and we're going to am I going too fast
fantastic good okay so we're going to
create a really really really basic
little array
facts and we're just gonna do and this
is gonna be the easiest little nodejs
script you've ever seen we're just gonna
console.log this fat and cool and now
we're gonna do it note index a a yes and
boom that's our fact one okay beautiful
we don't have to applause yet
plaws later love applause all if you
want applause I'll take the applause
okay all right so this was great but
what do we really want to do we want
something to randomly grab one item from
that array right now of course we could
totally just go ahead and say um mascot
random mascot floor some algorithm in
you know what someone has probably
already written this because it is the
most commonly used code for any
randomizer so let's just see if maybe a
package like that already exists so what
we gonna do we're gonna go to NP MJS
calm and we're going to open up the
search and I know what you're thinking
you're gonna say Vachel and cams are
just terrible not anymore
alright so what do we see here just kind
of we just put in a little search for
random array and hey would you look at
that get a random item from an array
that's exactly what we're looking for
Thank You syndra Soros okay so we're
going to take a look at that package
page and sounds cool so in order to
install it we do an NPM install - - to
save random item and then we're gonna we
have an API for using it so let's go
ahead and do that we're going to say and
p.m. install random item - save
beautiful fantastic and the reason why
we do - - save is because again we want
that package JSON manifest to kind of
have all of our dependencies listed in
there and we could do it Ottoman we
could do it ourselves but I'm a lazy
developer and I hope you're a lazy
developers - so why do it ourselves when
the when the you know program can do it
for us plus it tells you it goes ahead
and saves the exact version that you're
using all the names
you don't worry about typos or anything
so if we wanted to take a look at the
package.json you can see right here we
have our random item dependency
beautiful okay now this is less of an
NPM thing and more of an ode practice
thing I don't always believe everything
I read on the internet so I'm gonna do a
little trust but ferret by type thing so
in case you're not aware node has a read
eval print loop also known as the repple
where you can kind of sandbox with
packages that you've installed and so as
long as you've already installed it into
the current directory you just as do
node and then you can kind of play with
a you can play with the the packages
that you've just pulled in and and you
can kind of just do okay so according to
the readme the API is just a Rando of
array and it should just pull okay cool
so this works exactly as I expect it's
pulling random ones fantastic
so now I'm gonna go ahead and update my
index a J yes to have this right am
andum item require random item and
update this to have random item and now
if I do node index J yes all right back
to fact to fact one alright cool so it's
doing exactly what we were asking for
beautiful okay so that worked exactly
the way we wanted and now I'm going to
so okay again really lazy I'm such a
lazy programmer I really don't like
writing node index dot G is over and
over and over again and what I'm about
to do is gonna make a go
you didn't actually make it better but I
want you to think about your own
applications where you're kind of like
when you're starting up your app maybe
it's not just a single point of entry
right maybe you have a gulp script that
you want to run before you start your
app up maybe you have a test suite that
you want to run before you start your
app up well we're gonna create an NPM
start script and the way that we do that
is we go into our package JSON
and we create a new script called start
and there are a few scripts that have
special keywords like start and test is
that you can just use NPM start and I'll
show you that in a second but you can
just do basically index node index dot J
yes and now if I do npm start it'll run
the exact same thing and so it's just a
little bit of an easier thing like i can
set whatever it is i want you can you
can also change that to be a bash script
if you really want it to but you can
just have it you can put it I just bash
straight into that into your package a
JSON so that's pretty cool but I don't
know if you noticed my my codes a little
wonky I've got some semicolon some
places and some semicolons not in other
places and you know missing so what's
one thing that I could do to kind of
clean up my code well I can use a
package like standard to go ahead and
clean this up because you know what am I
doing here again I don't want to have to
think about this I want to have other
other modules take care of this for me
so I'm going to go ahead and and Pam
install standard and again I'm lazy you
don't have to use and can install you
can just do NPM I and I'm gonna do a - -
save - dev I can also change this to
just - D with a capital D now so here's
the thing about standard and actually
any module usually you would kind of
install it globally with a - G kind of
like we did with NPM but it turns out
you don't ever I mean ever have to
install a module globally so especially
if you have an application that you're
working on and other people on your team
are also working on the exact same thing
you know sometimes you're like oh shoot
I completely forgot to tell you have to
install this one thing globally you
don't have to do that ever ever ever
again just install it as a dev
dependency because you're the whole
point of dev dependencies versus regular
dependencies is that your dev
dependencies don't need to go into
production they have nothing to do with
your actual code it's just kind of sad
stuff so okay so you've your dev
dependency in there and then I'm gonna
go ahead and create a new rum script
and I'm gonna call it standardized and
Amna dues runs standard and what that's
going to do for me is I can do npm run
standardized and because standard is a
it's not a reserved word so like start
or test you have to use the word run
there you can't just say npm
standardized you NPM run standardized
and so there were a whole bunch of
errors oh my gosh why well it's because
standard had a bunch of errors and it
said hey look you you had extra
semicolons and that was really gross cuz
standard apparently doesn't like
semicolons whatever standard fine
compromise you're doing the job that I
want to do so uh the recommended fix is
- standard - - fix now a lot of people
kind of would say oh well I guess I'll
have to create a brand new start startup
script or NPM run script so that I can
have a - - fix in there but fun fact you
could just as easily and Pam run
standardized if you add a - - right
after your run script you can add
parameters that you would normally add
to your command line and so I basically
just ran - - fix on the NPM run
standardized and you can see what
essentially happened is it ran standard
- - fix for me so that's pretty cool -
okay so from there good okay so now I
want to build another module I want to
build a module of wombat facts right
now the difference between a package and
a module is that a package is something
that you would that you can kind of
install with NPM but a module is
something that you can actually use with
nodes module loader so you'd use the
require syntax and so not all packages
or modules but all modules or packages
ish but yeah so we're gonna do is I like
to modulate my code I like to break it
up into different pieces and I just
think about well what kinds of modules
would other people want to use I have no
idea what kind of things people would
want with what random on that facts but
that's cool we're going to
bill that anyway so let's go and create
a brand new directory called wombat
facts mmm and we're gonna go into that
directory now creating a module is the
exact same process as creating an
application we're gonna do an NPM in it
now here's the thing about NPM in it if
I'm totally cool with all of the little
automated bits and pieces I can just say
unpin minute - - yes and it'll take care
of it for me you can also do just a
regular - why and so no it doesn't have
the description or the keywords you know
what I'm lazy and that happened really
fast I did you press ENTER like a whole
bunch of times so that's pretty nice and
now I'm going to go again into index -
is but because I'm creating a module I
need you module dot exports and I'm
going to create this fact one in fact
two in fact three and that's all
fantastic and so that's cool and what I
think a lot of people would do right now
is they would kind of publish with some
sort of alpha thing or whatever to try
to test it on their other application
you don't have to do that thing is I
don't want anybody to accidentally
download this right now I just wanted to
check to see if it works in my regular
application so I'm going to use is a
thing called an cam link and what an cam
link does is it creates a sim link
between your your working directory and
a directory and user local Lib node
modules and then I'm gonna go ahead and
go back to my random wombat fax
application and I'm going to do NPM link
wombat fax and what that does is it
creates another sim link from that user
or local Lib node modules and puts it
straight into my node modules now for if
you were wondering node modules is where
all of your packages live and so so
that's pretty neat and now if I were to
now it's kind of like you had just
installed it even though I didn't really
install it because I didn't really
publish it now I can go into my index a
Jas and I can change these facts here to
require wombat facts and if all goes
well if I can just do NPM start
and I should still get fact one fact
three or whatever but if you're a little
bit like okay wait but it said fact one
in fact two facts three before that's
cool let's go ahead and update our index
at Jassim real wombat facts and so
here's some real wombat facts and note I
haven't done anything I don't need to
NPM link again I don't need to do I need
to publish or anything and I'm just
gonna go ahead I just changed
directories back into my random wombat
facts app and I'm gonna NPM start and
turns out they have a backwards facing
pouch like other marsupials wombats give
Berk to a tiny underdeveloped baby that
calls into its mother's pouch to grow
and develop further but wombats pouches
have a special difference they are
positioned backwards opening toward the
mothers rear rather than their head this
allows her to dig without getting dirt
in her pouch that's a pretty cool little
fact also wombats have slow metabolisms
it takes the wombat up to 14 days to
digest a meal this low metabolism helps
them out and they're hot and dry habitat
so very cool I think it's pretty cool
okay
alright now I'm ready to go ahead and
publish this module the first thing when
I do is into NPM unlink so it kills it
takes out that at that sim link and now
I'm going to go ahead and publish it now
keep in mind that in order to publish
you need to have an account on NPM you
can either NPM you can NPM log in and I
think you can do an NPM signup I think
it might be an M camp sign up so you can
do that on the CLI or you can just go to
the website and create an account there
or if you already have an account then
just make sure you NPM log in for sure
now I'm a little weary about creating a
wombat facts like high-level module me
because somebody else already took the
name or I'm just not sure I'm ready to
do have that kind of commitment to the
public so what I could do is I can scope
this module and what that means is I can
put it under my username scope usually
we think about scopes as an organization
scope which you have to pay for your
company has to pay for orgs or a private
scope like a solo account where you can
basically create private modules but
guess what
you can totally create public scoped
modules to and the way that we do that
is we go into our package a JSON I'm
going to change this to at rockbot slash
wombat fax and if you're ever curious
about if you're logged in or not if you
just do NPM Who am I
it'll tell you who you're logged in as
so good good trick and so now I can do
and PM publish with a dash dash access
equals public so with that that allows
you to create a public scoped module and
it should work so now I've published it
and I can go ahead and take a look at
this if you're wondering about this
thing it's I'm using Alfred fax and lo
and behold here we go I've published it
and it's a version 1.0.0 and that's
fantastic ooh um oh no no readme found
what do we do
let's go ahead and create a repeat and
so we're just gonna kind of do a really
quick read me and now when you create a
readme it's not really a major change to
your module instead it's just kind of
like a little thing so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna bump my patch version I'm
gonna put my version to bump the patch
and so you can actually use NPM version
patch and so you can do patch minor or
major and I'll talk about that in just
second and then you can add a little bit
of a tag like I'm creating a readme or
something like that and what version
will do is it'll not only update your
version number but it'll also create a
new commit if you have a github repo
it'll create a new commit with all of
these updates and it'll create a new get
tag so when you push up make sure you
remember to get push and get pushed
- tags but I don't have a github repo
for this project right now so ignore
that but if I do an NPM publish again
now as soon as it publishes I should be
able to find that pack now there should
be a readme tada
okay fantastic
okay so let's say I totally didn't like
this at all and I really want I just was
not a fan so I can unpublish and I can
just say unpublish and what end him
unpublished tends to do is if you only
have one little module if you only have
one version it'll go ahead and delete
that one version or it'll unpublish just
one pieces of it but specifically it's
good to say explicitly what version you
want to unpublish so I can you know NPM
unpublish rock that one about facts at
one point 0.0 because I really didn't
like the fact that didn't have a readme
so cool I can unpublish that or if I
want to unpublish everything I can
unpublish with a dash F or a dash dash
force and that one publish the entire
package in its entirety and you know I
we sure hope you know what you're doing
when you do that but then as you will
see it's not found it's totally gone now
one major thing that a lot of people try
to do is they'll go hey wait a second I
I want to I want to publish I want to
republish version 1.0.0 well let me tell
you that is not a good idea and here's
why let's talk about semver for a second
miles borns is going to go a little bit
more in detail about some verse I'm just
gonna do a really really high level
version but with December some very
semantic versioning it is a handshake
that you do with the rest of the
developer community at least within the
NPM land where you basically say I
promise
I sure do solemnly swear that I am up to
very good and what you're basically
saying is whatever this number is when I
make a change I will update this number
to reflect the type of change that I'm
about to do so the the last digit is
going to be your patch and that's
something that's like okay if I have
some bug fixes or I forgot to add a
readme
doesn't actually affect the code that
much it's just gonna be like this tiny
tiny thing now you can use NPM version
patch to to bump that and then if you
have a minor so if you change the middle
number that's because you've added some
new features maybe you've extended your
API or you've you know just kind of made
something a little bit cooler so that's
a minor that's npm version minor and
then if you have a major breaking change
like your deprecating a function you are
completely rewriting how a function
works you're using modules that have
also totally had massive breaking
changes then you're gonna go ahead and
bump that in major and that's NPM
version major and so again this is a
handshake that you're making with the
rest of the community when somebody
comes in and to support and says hey I
accidentally unpublished my version 1.0
point
oh and I don't want to create a new
version 1.0 point one can I just rewrite
1.0 point oh no you can't and the reason
for that is that you've now violated the
handshake that's kind of like giving
somebody a present and saying hi I
bought you a present it's this really
amazing cake and it's chocolate and
delicious and then saying oh wait a
second I'm just gonna take that back and
then and then you kind of like give them
like a vanilla cake instead and it's
like a vanilla cake is good but it's not
the chocolate one that you gave me
originally why why what happened my
chocolate cake right and slowly that's
the community is expecting you to uphold
this and here's the fun fact versions
are cheap they're completely free
they're completely free so it's totally
okay if you have to bump your version
number but you know a little patch a
point point 0.1 so cool there's more
there's totally more there's always more
but we don't have time for all of that
unfortunately so here are a few things
for you to totally look up fun of
dependencies and kim shrink-wrap their
configuration options that will totally
make your whole workflow a lot better
this tags an NPM Pakenham deprecated NPM
update so many things how will you ever
learn about at them all good at dockside
NPM Jas calm it has every single bit of
documentation that we currently
have about all of our products all of
our services all of those good things
and if you need help that's totally fine
come to our support page there you can
fill out a form to contact us or you can
just email us or you can tweet at us or
you can even take a look at our issue
tracker and create issue tracker or
create issues on our issue trackers for
the command line interface the website
or the registry so come like come say hi
please fill out bugs we depend on you
and we know how much you depend on us so
go out build some really really cool
stuff come talk to me I will give you
stickers in exchange and you know chat
with me on the Twitter isn't stuff to
all right thank you so much
[Applause]